Want the place,
but he was making so much money.
He couldn't fucking Cleveland.
It was 1984.
It was too fast.
Wow.
And they fucking blew.
Can you imagine that?
Getting blown up in a fucking pipe bomb.
That's where you know somebody
and he didn't die right away.
The metal went up in his ass.
He stayed awake for hours.
We went up in his plate under the jeep and shit.
They all have those crash plates in Colorado.
They all have those plates.
Those plates were working against you and you have a bomber.
The fucking car.
So the point went right this fucking Cooley's.
So he was just bleeding a.
that's fucking crazy.
When somebody kills you with a car bomb the shit that means you did something
bad.
They slice your throat.
You've got to be a ghost at the slicers.
Your drawer.
You'll never arrest arrested fucking piece.
You got to be something.
You know,
a ghost haunting the woods forever.
Wanted somebody,
your husband,
Colombians.
Anything.
Fucking Brian Redman.
What's up,
Brian?
Michael,
do you believe in ghosts?
Joey Diaz.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck you.
I don't believe that I seen.
I seen something at the comedy store.
One thing not,
I didn't see the door ringing.
I didn't see nobody walking in with.
Not a head on.
I mean I've heard a lot of stories in economies.
Look.
And then I've been around people who pass spirits as a young child.
In fact,
I went to see the lady when I went home last week.
Yeah,
that was a kid.
I've seen the do some wild shit.
What'd you do when that was about a woman who was about eight,
you know,
my mother had a bar and all these people coming in to shake it down,
cops would come and nice guys,
just white guys come in and that's part of the business.
When you have a bar,
you know,
somebody gets stabbed,
you want the cops there first,
you got to give her an envelope,
you know?
And then,
uh,
after about three months,
his guy started coming.
It was a Cuban guy,
looked like separate goal,
but he would come in and break the Cubans balls.
He went after Cubans.
He wouldn't have to Cubans in 76 and 75.
You wouldn't have to run heavy and he would come into my mother's bar in Salta
and fuck you motherfuckers,
I want a bigger envelope next time I come,
that type of shit.
So when that went in there after school and he was yelling and screaming in,
they're not in like this fucking guy.
He was younger and he had a beard and he was a weightlifting type dude.
Somebody's couple of weeks later I go to the bar and it's all these Cuban guys.
They had a ball and 38th street they had the brandies.
These will all Cuban bookmakers that my dad knew,
my stepdad and my mom do.
Nice fucking people.
And it was this lady.
I played basketball with the kids.
A kid was a boxer.
His name was Jose Torres bad.
Their uncles,
the fucking dude.
That's their uncle.
The Kuda Jose Torres.
He's a boxing ref or something big boxing official.
That's their uncle.
This is their nephew,
their Puerto Rican.
So I was the guy that was.
He was a light heavyweight champion.
Right.
You know he something big with boxing.
This is his nephew.
I grew up with that nephew.
They were basketball players.
I think that's what I'm talking about isn't even one that wrote the book about
Mike Tyson.
He kind of grew up with Mike Tyson and kind of like wrote a tell all book about
them.
I was Kinda like Kinda shitty.
None of this is Joe Torres.
Yeah,
that's.
This is Jose Torres,
the referee from the seventies and thinking of the wrong
guy.
I don't think this guy even raft like a.
He was.
He was the one that did our fight when they were trying to stop it.
The ran against when they were trying to stop it.
He's the.
We got to look it up.
Duran Duran against that fight.
When he killed the guy in the ring and the guy died two weeks later,
but he took the spirit of what?
What's the fight we always talk about with David?
I think he had died years later in a car.
The car accident or the fucking Jack Philanthropic got crushed.
But he,
I took his spirit,
his spirit that happens to guys.
Man.
Did Julio Cesar Chavez when he fought Meldrick Taylor,
there's no question about that fight.
Meldrick Taylor got a spirit taking.
Chavez took his spirit.
He hurt them bad to physically,
like he was never the same physically,
but he was also number the same psychologically to go through that crazy ass war
and to be boxing the fucking ears off the guy at first.
Then eventually the guy just slowly wears you down,
slowly wears you down,
and then boom stops you in the twelfth with like seconds to go.
They stopped the fight.
Like that's a crushing blow,
a devastating blow,
you know,
that's a to to have the referee look at you when there's like,
was it like two seconds left on the clock and the referees shakes him off.
And Chavez winds like,
what?
What?
That's like a spirit crusher.
Well,
talking about the spirit with Jose Torres.
So we were kids and once a month this lady would pass a fucking spirit in the
house.
She would go.
She was on mom.
No,
this lady was a mom.
I used to watch her.
She was a mom.
She used to drive her kids around to different basketball games and shit.
Her husband and her was separated.
She wasn't a boozer.
She never really cursed.
I would go with in the daytime and she would make sandwiches for you and stuff
like that.
She would take the kids to church on Sundays,
so I used to watch it,
but my mother once told me that said that lady passes a fucking weird spirit
once a month or some shit and people go over there and you bring them money or
gifts or whatever the fuck you bring in and she talks to you show one night.
We wasn't to him with the spirit.
So one night we went over there.
Now how long have you known me?
Time.
Look at me.
I don't fuck around.
Shut the fuck up Brian.
Fuck.
When I talked to you for like a man I talked to you like a man.
This is fucked up but I'm going to tell you I'm about eight or nine.
So this one.
Last time I went to the bar and he had them all up at the ball.
Like Popeye Doyle had those people in fucking,
uh,
the French connection memory when he goes in and he says,
everybody against the wall,
this is the last time I went in there and now he's fucking Cuban's pitch.
My Mom's pissed.
So like we got to figure something out.
And I knew eventually my dad was going to shoot this guy.
That's the.
I just had a funny feeling and my Stepdad or some of these on the shoot this
fucking guy because he was going over his bounds.
They felt that he was abusing Cubans,
which is even worse when you're Cuban.
If he was a white dude or a black dude,
hey,
it's part of the turf.
You're fucking Cuban.
We're going to get your ass.
So I knew about this and I just turned the other way.
One night we go to this lady's house and she's talking to these people and she's
got the spirit.
Now I'm wanting to sleep.
This lady would drink fucking rule alcohol.
What's that?
Fucking don't know the shit that people drink.
That's 140 proof.
Oh Claire,
you just drink it and talk to you and smoke a cigar.
Oh my God.
She was supposed to be a black African fucking slave,
but she was really a Puerto Rican woman and she plucked it and drink the fucking
shit and she was talking to my mother and she came over there.
I was a little fucking kid.
Doug and I remember looking at his shit in my pants off and she took a dish and
she showed it to my mom is a white dish and then she took a fucking candle and
she took the dishes.
She put the candle under the dish.
She took the candle,
she drew it down.
She showed the dish to my mother.
She said,
this is what's bothering you lately,
and it was just some fucking thing.
It just looked like some candle designer the thing,
right.
She took the dish,
she smashed it.
She goes,
done seven days.
I went home,
Doug and never thought about this shit again.
I was eight or nine.
I had Gi joes.
I was trying to look at my dad's pornos.
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
I don't believe this hocus pocus or one day I got out of school and I take the
bike and I go to my mother's bomb when I get up there,
they're all fucking drinking and having a good time at 3:30 and I go,
what happened?
They go,
they know that fucking cop.
They shot him to pieces last night and they shot him up by this place.
Rapido tax.
He was the first Cuban taxi cab company in the seventies that would deliver
blown the taxis.
All these geniuses that Jesus.
Now the Cubans are doing that.
The 17 union city,
they will go over the bridge.
You call from the city.
They live in the studio.
Fifty four would deliver that.
Come on though because it's 74 slash 75.
Come on dark.
And the name of the company was rapido taxi,
you know,
wrap it on means in Spanish.
But quick bitch quit little quick,
quick,
quick.
So I took my bike to rather than Joe Rogan,
I went up to this.
Fuck.
This is really.
It was the taxi,
a taxi company,
taxi company,
but the delivered fucking blow.
That was the,
that was the purpose of we.
They made money on a $3 toll.
They make money delivering the fucking goody good.
The studio.
That's how did they run a real taxi too?
Because we'll tax.
You can take it from the supermarket.
Go on the way home.
Can you get me some coke right?
No,
no,
no.
I'm away home.
You got to go to the city.
They just put a keel over the city and they don't get pulled over.
You got a ride in the city?
Are you pulling me over to Joe Rogan in the back of the car?
I'm sorry.
Go right ahead.
We thought you were doing something else.
Meanwhile his fucking bag of fucking blown the trunk and the cops must have been
on a tear.
Right.
How much or how many of the cops were in on it back then?
I don't fucking know.
New York.
New York was a different.
New York was a different fucking animal then,
but you got to remember that it was just a taxi.
Nobody thought about that when New York back then.
That was 20 years ahead of that fucking time.
When,
when New York's needs,
bro,
everybody else caught a fucking cold.
Let's get down to that 10 years behind over here and he's fucking savages.
You know,
this is a totally different place socially than New York,
that's for sure.
Right now.
You think people are more on the ball there?
There's more like there's more con artists and shit.
There's more clever people did anything that's more fucking Douche bags
everywhere.
People here I think.
Yeah,
there's
a lot of that,
but I think that I always say something about the weather man.
You don't have to deal with the weather.
You get soft,
you know your brain doesn't have to think,
think quickly because you have to survive.
You know when you're in Boston and it's fucking zero degrees out and you get in
your car and it goes,
fuck,
fuck woo.
And you don't have a cell phone.
Stupid.
There was no cell phones back then.
So what are you doing?
Oh my God,
I've got to knock on someone's door so I don't freeze to death.
You got to wake some people up because you might freeze to death.
I'm sorry,
I'm in my car broke down.
Can I use your dude?
You got to think quicker when you're in that kind of an environment in
California,
you know your car breaks down,
you just sleep in the car until you know the cops come and then the cops tell
you what's going on.
Oh my car broke down and they get you a tow truck and you find you don't have to
worry about dying outside.
Living in Boston,
you got to worry about dying.
That's like some real shit and that's why they're there a little quicker,
a little quicker on a take.
That sounds
the sound,
that sound that you made for doing the car.
I was just imagining.
I was imagining that's what it sounded like when Joey Diaz had sex.
Do you think so jody?
Like when you have sex,
it's more,
it was good,
Dick that I tell you.
I'm giving you.
I'm giving you good.
Don't get me started.
I'll have you know who he had 20 minutes.
Bitch slap and motherfuckers.
You know what I'm saying?
Who you have here?
What the fuck?
What's plan b?
You know,
do you know?
So
dog,
Trixie,
vixen got a raped again,
girl by a girl dog.
The person was like,
I gotTa pee while you tell the story.
The person I was with him
Joey and Wednesday man,
because my story are so the person that was worth it own the dog.
They were like,
my dog has never a humped anything and be my dog is a girl dog.
So I don't even know why.
It's like trying to hump your dog's ass because it doesn't have a dick.
So Joey,
what,
what do you think about rss feeds?
I have no idea what David fucking up here.
Why are you bothering me for a little about computers?
You don't know anything about computers.
What will you take a bottle that says,
uh,
whether designed to a pump out a,
like if you have a website,
it's designed only for,
were mostly for,
uh,
sending out your website.
So other applications and other websites can add it to their website and their
applications.
But if you don't want to do that,
you don't have an rss feed.
So I could see you wouldn't want an rss feed.
Love to me about something
like,
Oh,
is that real?
That's really.
See now that's why you wanted to take.
We'll get employees walking right into the.
And I had to pee.
I'm sorry,
Ladies and gentlemen,
I,
I was working on that video game all day today.
Like Gyros.
I was working on that UFC video game today and I drink tea when I work on that
show.
The video game is like,
it's very a script and there's like I have to pretend that like fights going on
for hours and hours and hours.
You're talking about that like really intense fast and,
and your,
your voice gets really tired because I had to drink a lot of tea so I could not
hold in my urine.
So what you were saying before I left so rudely is that your dog's a whore,
a whore,
that lesbians are raping your daughter.
No.
Yeah,
exactly.
And like why do all dogs have just the intuition to get on top of another dog
and Hump it even if they don't have a dick?
Because it doesn't make sense.
No,
it does.
My dog used to do that.
She was a female pit bull and I had a male pit bull that was a puppy and she
used to get on top of them and hump them just like rubbing pussies and no,
no.
It's a dominant thing.
So what she's doing is saying that if I wanted to fuck you in the ass,
I could,
I can get to the position where I'm on top of you.
I'm stronger than you.
Like they jockey for position.
You have to almost like it's,
it's,
it's a social thing.
It's like for a dog to be able to get on top of you and dry hump you.
It's not just that he's Horny,
it's also that he's trying to let you know he can do that.
He can impose himself on you.
Like my two dogs,
they have very clear rules like Johnny's a mastiff,
he's a big fucking dog and you know,
he's got this giant fucking head and he's a sweetheart of a dog,
but the other dogs,
a bull dog,
Shiba inu banks and the other dog doesn't get no say and shit.
That's just the way it is.
They don't fight,
they don't argue,
but when I opened up the door,
johnny walks in first.
Every time,
every time the other dog will stop and let Johnny go through first.
Why?
Because Johnny a 140 pound master,
if he's fucking huge,
you know,
so there's just clear rules.
If Johnny wanted to hunt Brutus,
he could get away with it,
but it brutus tried to Hump Johnny.
There would be chaos.
It would be like,
what the fuck?
Buddhist probably would growl and snap at Johnny.
Johnny tried to Hump Them,
but the point is the other way is absolutely preposterous.
It's never going to happen.
There's like a this with animals,
there's an Alpha and then there's the ones who give in to the Alpha and your dog
clearly is like the most Beta dog ever.
I know.
It's so much dog food and we gave her.
Is that what it is dog?
So I guess the way it works is that they just feel her submissiveness and they
want a mount her.
Their instinct is to mount her and dominator.
And this,
the old dog I used to have was always a bad dog and every time it was bad I
would just like kind of put her in between my legs and my arm and kind of
getting like a crouching position and kind of just like put her in between me
and like hold her.
And so I was kind of like on top of her,
it wasn't like fucking earnings,
you know,
she was just like on like underneath my belly,
like a little cave I would make.
I would just sit there for like 10 minutes and you can tell the dog at first
trying to get out.
And then finally just kind of some this are,
you know,
just kind of lays down and it gives up.
Dog is just fine,
you know,
just walks around.
I don't think you're supposed to do that.
I think you fucked up your dog's head,
raped your dog.
Every time it shit on carpet and every time it sits in the car,
but you rate it.
Well No,
no.
It's something I learned kind of from a Caesar.
Caesar does he?
After showtime,
after nights,
showtime version of it.
Now he,
he,
he says secret.
Yeah,
probably be the best way to do it.
Yeah.
He said,
well he didn't say it like that.
He said that you should grab it by the back of the neck and like hold it down
for awhile,
but that's pretty much what I was doing.
I was pretty much getting on top of it and just kind of like getting like,
Yo,
I am the master here.
It's the whole dog thing is crazy man.
Do you have these animals that listened to you right now?
Like what the fuck?
What's wrong with us?
There's not another animal that keeps animals that they love.
You know,
it's weird and we've got an engineered to be like the sweetest,
nicest things ever.
I mean,
look at your dog.
Your dog's ridiculously affectionate.
I've never seen a dog but not just affectionate,
but she's so needy to her.
It's like every breath,
but like taking a breath.
She needs that much attention.
Like it's like as much as she's breathing,
she someone touching her as much as she needs to take him there.
She needs someone to touch her.
It's like that extreme,
right?
A stripper or something way worse.
Way Worse since does.
Is there any animal that has pubic hair?
I've never taken the other day.
I was like,
wouldn't it be cool if animals have pubic hairs and like term or you could just
get a full Bush,
you know,
like if you're it,
the animal would have to have nothing else around it.
I mean they have pubic hair over their whole fucking body.
That's basically what's going on.
Yeah,
kind of.
Sure.
But I mean like,
like even like bald eagles,
Bald Eagles,
that bushes.
Those are feathers.
But I mean like,
why don't they have.
Are you talking about Bald Eagles have penises,
right?
Yes.
Why are humans the only ones that have a pubic hairs?
Because we don't have hair on the rest of our body.
There's very few animals that have exposed very few animals that have exposed
skin.
That ain't shit.
Dude.
If you were a viewer,
a coyote,
I would take him to the vet.
I believe this poor thing is dying because all his hair is missing.
When you think is Harry is only Harry to a hairless person.
You know I'm covered in here too.
That's not Harry is.
That's your hairless.
You just.
You have a little hair compared to the other healers folks.
Why don't monkeys have huge bushes?
They do ban.
They do.
They have pubic hairs.
Don't get long and crazy like ours because they just have different kinds of
hair,
but they have hair around their dick and balls.
The fuck is wrong with you son.
You're going to do some research before you come up with these crazy pubic hair
theories.
I mean,
they don't have bushes like talking about the biggest.
We don't have it anywhere else.
It would be weird if like animals,
you know?
I mean there's no the only animal that's like us that his hair and certain parts
of his body is like some some dogs and I just wish all men.
Why don't give a fuck about animal pubic?
It'd be all worried about people dying of radiation poisoning and Japan and
fucking.
Why are we in Libya?
The CIA's involvement,
our life.
I'm worried about animals
think Peter would exist if animals have hairs.
Ryan,
don't let me get built
in the ass or this last time with fucking brock lesnar right now.
Can you put into the microphone bro?
I'm straight.
My voice is too big.
I blow the speakers might be called dog.
Alright.
What's going on in the pilborough did a video where a,
he fucking talked about the thing that is a video on youtube.
So he made it six minutes long.
He talked about the argument on his own for another six minutes and at the end
of it he goes,
yeah.
And I was right.
That's the point.
That guy,
that guy,
he doesn't know about computers and they're trying to rip you off and take the
money for the artists.
They never had money for the artist fucking rss feeds.
You know what?
You know what the thing that bugged me the most,
six minutes.
This is expensive.
Talking to him.
The thing that bugged me the most,
I met him like four times,
five times before,
right?
He even did I,
we did a,
uh,
a comedy show that the following night or that night,
that night we did a comedy show and knows the following the following night and
I was like,
the host of this show and I'm like,
he knew that I'm a comic.
Awesome.
He's knows who I am right now.
And if he's Nice fucking whatever.
So he and the beginning of the video,
he goes,
yeah.
So there's that guy,
that little guy that whatever,
that the male assisting guy,
fucking male assistant to something over there,
this guy,
whatever the fuck he is,
give me a jay route.
Come on,
but,
but fuck that,
that the thing that bugs me the most is.
And I,
I was pretty baked when that argument happened,
but the thing that bugged me the most about everything was my whole thing wasn't
that I'm like,
yeah,
what stitchers doing is 100 percent legal.
No,
what?
What I was saying is if you have something on your website that you put on your
website that is only put on your website,
if you want to broadcast to your stuff,
if you don't want that,
then take it off your website.
It doesn't change anything.
My whole argument is like,
why do you have an rss feed on your website?
Why?
What?
Why did you put it on?
Are we really having this conversation?
What are you doing?
No,
but I'm already so my art,
but my argument that I'm just saying,
know your argument was brought it up.
Here we go again.
Here we go.
No,
it.
His argument is,
I know what your argument is.
I'm aware of the general details of the disagreement.
I know,
but how?
How is how is what I'm saying is that's not a wrong or right thing.
That's just a question now
actually anymore.
I don't care anymore.
What's way more fascinating to me is how involved you to gut.
That was way more fun.
Fascinating.
When you're getting a tax issues,
trying to explain to somebody
the actual issue was minuscule compared to how psychologically captivating it
was and how he was genuinely getting upset and you were getting upset too and I
was trying to mediate because I generally did see both sides.
I genuinely did,
but what I couldn't understand is how you guys are getting so God damn upset and
then when I would bring it up building it.
Oh,
this is the fucking new spa Joe Rogan Joe Rogan from 1994 with a fucking stab
somebody by now.
We didn't even know each other back then.
Man.
You're just assuming you're assuming I would have done that.
Well,
you know what it was just to me it was like I've already said the same five
times.
I.
I can't say anything else about that.
I couldn't get you guys to stop.
It was fascinating.
You would like to.
Dogs Bark like,
shut up.
Bye Bye.
Bye.
Starting there also comes to a point where you are like,
feel like you're talking to your mom doing email.
That's how I get about certain things.
You must have saw his point a little bit.
No,
I see what he's saying,
but that's not what I'm saying.
I'm not saying I agree with him or disagree with them on that.
He wasn't willing to listen to what you were saying about the whole concept of
an rss feed,
which stands for really simple syndication and what syndication mean.
You want to syndicate.
Yeah.
What's that mean?
It's you want to spread it out to as many people as possible.
Absolutely available on your website.
Absolutely,
but the real problem was the real problem is itunes numbers and that's what he
really wants to say is that sticker was helping hurting his items,
numbers and probably that he doesn't know what an rss feed is,
why it's on his website.
If he wants people to go to his website,
take off your rss feed,
that's all you have to do.
Make.
Don't make your rss feed public.
Just give it to Itunes,
only hide your rss feed and then everyone will come to your website and you'll
have your items.
Only one.
We do one better than that.
We allow people to download it and not just on Stitcher,
but allow people to download it directly,
so the moment it goes live,
I have a download link so I don't want.
You have to wait till somebody itunes numbers will be higher.
Like to me all that matters is that you get it out there,
you don't get cookies for being number three or number four or you know,
it's cute.
It's nice to see the number,
but what's important to me is just that it gets distributed to as many people as
possible as easily as possible.
Some people don't like fucking with itunes.
Some dudes who love the Zune.
You know?
I heard the New Zealand is pretty bad ass.
I think they stopped making them bro.
Oh,
did they?
Yeah,
I lied on my ass.
I mean there's some people
that have just little MP.
Three players was a little flash MP.
Three players were like a little.
You know what I mean?
It's like he got to have it available for everything in anybody.
No voids,
and especially when it's.
If it's a free thing that you just want to get out your podcast to people,
you're.
No,
you're not.
You're not doing like Doug Benson where you're charging money.
You're just trying to get your body just calling out Doug Benson.
I can't believe the fee.
The honest thing is the future of podcasts,
how our podcasts is going to make money.
What Doug is doing is pretty interesting.
He's charging money now for like certain shows.
I don't think it's every shoe.
I think it's like he has like certain shows.
Marin does that too.
It's like something where you become like some super members on shit.
Right?
I mean,
I honestly think the only way really to make money and to get sponsors got to
get a lot a lot of listeners and get sponsors.
That's the way to do it,
right?
I think.
I think because I think we've just reached this time on the Internet.
We have to look at the music industry and we have to say,
look,
the music industry has changed.
It's not that people started stealing and taking shit from,
from the music industry.
Is that happened and that there was no way to stop that,
so the music industry has to reorganize,
refigure out how they do it and that's going to happen with everything and you
can't fucking stop it.
You just gotta go with what you think is going to happen and that's like
podcasting.
No one knows what's happening with podcasting,
but you have to pretty much go with what you can do
right now.
We'll try to have the luxury thing.
We also have the luxury of doing other things,
you know,
I have the luxury of not having to rely completely on my podcast with the UFC
and we're doing standup especially with doing standup because the podcast
definitely enhances the standard insanely.
And,
and also just look at Philly,
Philly,
you just sold out all affiliate,
right?
Yeah,
it's sold out.
It's two weeks from now.
I mean how,
when was the last time that happened?
It wasn't happening like that before.
It's like that everywhere it.
Seattle last weekend was fucking crazy man.
1,800 people.
And when I asked them,
I'm like,
how many guys were listening to podcast?
It was like the whole crowd.
It was 100 percent of the crowd.
Do you get that now?
Joy.
I get people yelling out.
Do Joe Diaz has changed completely.
And with music which really going on with music is that they had to give it
away.
So now you make money performing at these bitches can't perform.
Yeah,
they're faking it.
Sorry.
They can't perform the music.
The music will use it.
Got Real auto tune over their voice.
And you know,
the allman brothers could show up with three white guys with fucking rocket
soca.
Whether it's good,
there's no they can do it.
The organist shit don't come through like God,
I believe that.
Good.
I want to go see fucking the black eyed peas to sing songs for fucking people
are one fucking song.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
But really 80 fucking dollars for the ticket to see that nonsense.
There's no musician store.
There's not that many.
The black keys are pretty fucking bad listening to black kids.
Yeah,
but they can't do fucking love the black kids.
Seriously.
I can't get enough.
Like anything they do.
I fucking love the shit they're.
They're on the right frequency.
They're on the radio frequency.
Listen,
they're real musicians.
Listen to king of the musicians right now is the Guy Dave Grohl,
better musician that's lived that spirit of this band,
the band,
the foo fighters there is bad because their students are the fucking gate.
Prince went to Vegas two years ago and did a show of request.
Really?
Can you imagine everything you hit print with.
He's going to play for,
I believe,
Elsa to fuck billy idol,
so people yell it out in the crowd and we just did $500 a ticket.
Bam.
Coming.
Y'All bitch aerosmith and people go and performance at the end.
Started flying out there just because I want to get an estate.
This motherfucker's going.
What do you want to hear?
Come together.
The Beatles.
Ready?
One,
two,
three,
four
down.
Now.
That's fucking.
That's why he was getting a little fucking ticket or get these tickets are
outrageous.
Now for these bands to the real deal.
He's a real musical genius.
You know?
He put out a lot of bad songs.
Unfortunately.
He.
There's a lot of his songs and I just then
he was experimenting with everything but they were still stuck in this bucket
and he was like,
Yo,
he had some great jams bro
Chances.
So there's,
some of them didn't come out and some of them is very self indulgent so his
style is,
you know,
sometimes it gets caught up and what he's doing,
but when he hit it,
erotic city,
come on son,
come on,
done.
That's a great God damn song.
I,
that was my.
During high school there was a,
they were trying to get that as our high school senior song,
erotic city.
We were,
it was a write in,
you know,
so we were all trying to like organize it and then someone listened to it.
Someone who worked for the school as it do it.
That was the end of that.
Do Do.
Oh,
it's fucking amazing.
He's done some great shit and that's what's really going on.
So everybody's got to have gone.
But it's amazing that somebody told me this two years ago and I really
experienced that last year in Irvine.
Last year was when I see the fruition of what you've been doing.
Somebody told me that now because of the Internet,
twitter and all the podcasts and people want the full experience and I didn't
really see it to last July.
If you noticed last July when I changed everything about my twitter,
my facebook,
I changed everything about it because they paid more attention to it.
How come I understand now where you're coming from?
There's no more.
I see what Ralphie may's doing.
I see what you're doing with these.
Wasted his time when he flies into a city a week before or two days to do radio.
That's a waste of time.
That's all that you're staying at home.
You don't have to do.
The thing about this game is to to make the most money for the least amount of
work.
That's why I don't like that.
It's not just that.
It's not that with as many people as you can,
but you have a wife,
you have children.
I don't want to chew in the Brassica Monday doing some radio show for what,
but I never did that anyway.
No,
I wouldn't.
I would never do it,
but I will look what you do with a blink of a fucking button.
You added an extra show in Australia three weeks ago with a blink of a couple
hours,
a couple of hours.
We put together a show on a Thursday night or differently.
Now that you've been talking about it for years.
It all came to fruition with a podcast or blog with twitter and you know I've
become an expert now at the twitter is now I know how to do it more.
You gotta give them something and then tweet something.
Give them something.
Not Every fucking stupid joke that comes out of your fucking mind because
everybody thinks if you're a monologist,
you're going to die on twitter because you got to sell the fucking joke.
If you to make a mind jumping on twitter,
it's not going to go nowhere.
Sometimes when you talk about your situation and twitter and then talk about a
free show or a show and then your situation,
it's different.
I answered every fucking body and on twitter I try to fuck with people on
twitter.
My twitter is a lot on facebook,
more Christians.
I got nephews and nieces.
I can't think of it.
I still throw out the blunt of life,
you know what I mean?
I don't give a fuck.
Get over it every now and then you hit him with.
I got to hit them with something every morning just to wake the morning and they
got to look at your shit.
Little 13 year old lady.
That motherhood Uncle Joe.
He wrote on his twitter today.
Mommy,
what's the uni by doing the afternoon.
Go Fuck Yourself.
That's the truth though.
That Tito tee shirts,
by the way folks,
they are being printed right now.
The if you ain't high by two in the afternoon and go fuck it.
Sorry.
Sophia told me he ordered up a couple thousand feet.
Ain't no joke does.
He was still viable because this year is cool.
So strong.
It's so strong.
If you've seen on the phone and I seen the such a strong shirt.
So the saying is so strong.
Dr. Hole when you sent it,
we repeated it like four times because it was so funny and it was the weirdest
thing because the guy,
I don't know to tell the story that the guy was smoking with Oscar for fucking
three Ds shift for Star Wars.
His name is Dykstra.
Oh yeah.
And I despite a band too,
and Dykstra was that the guy in charge of all the fucking crazy three.
Our Three d guy,
the special effects,
special effects.
His name is.
He's a genius.
He's a fucking genius.
When you talked to him and he has a little daughter,
if you watch spiderman two after I stick up for us by the minute as a little
girl on the train that says me too.
That's his daughter and his daughter was telling everybody on the train the suck
a dick.
He was 12.
Something like that though.
That's my father.
Shut up,
sit down.
But the only way she dug was me because I would give it to her.
You know what I'm saying?
Like what's up?
Sit down.
Will you think talking to Joey Bananas,
the baby.
I was so big that they wouldn't put me on the train.
They just go check it.
So I come into Spiderman,
I check in and then I go eat and go to my room.
They put me in a room,
not even in the trailer.
So I would go to my room and smoke pot.
I told you about this.
I go get ready.
I go raping somebody,
keeps smoking dope in my room,
but I get to the bottom of this.
Go Joe here.
I don't know.
And it was me the whole time.
So one day dykes were figuring it out.
He goes,
things nobody's smoking.
Do you think you getting over on him?
It's fucking me.
Where is it?
What's behind the building?
So we go behind the building.
Like one day it was smoke and we go behind the building again.
The one they were smoking,
the third day comes,
some fucking PA comes,
you know how they get some type of an older woman like 42.
She came back,
then she seen us and she goes,
let a whatever they're looking for you,
are you smoking pot?
What's wrong with you?
And I sat for a minute,
I got all like,
there is something wrong with me.
What's wrong with me?
What's wrong with you?
If you will fucking high,
you wouldn't be worried about us not smoking high.
It was like 10,
15 in the morning.
I meant to say it's 10:00 in the morning and how the hell can you be smoking
pot?
You really smoking pot,
why wouldn't you?
And that's what we came up with.
A name for it.
But we will fuck what's wrong with you?
Fuck is wrong with me.
What's wrong with you?
Bitch?
You Ain't fucking problem.
And you were high.
You wouldn't worry about me smoking dope.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a weird thing where people want to stop you from doing something because
they think it's an indulgence.
You know,
they,
you're,
you're being weak.
Indulging.
You know,
my wife said to me two days ago,
she goes,
you know what?
The funny thing is at 5:30 in the morning,
I can hear the alarm go off.
But I heard you do a water bong hit.
That's when you.
I told me Tuesday morning,
she goes,
you know,
I didn't hear the alarm,
but I definitely heard your bong hit bong in the bedroom.
I got a bong in the office.
Then the office door,
they step off into the office and fire it up.
Oh.
When I get up,
I brush my teeth.
I piss and put the coffee on and I feed the cats and I go right for that.
I pray for 10 million.
You'll wake and bake like a motherfucker.
I used to wake and bake.
That fucks up your whole day.
You wait five minutes.
I got real balance out the body.
Eight a little candle up to balance out the Ph to get the fucking bottles.
Moving.
Cantaloupe.
Hmm.
I think it does up if you take it,
if you can bake,
it fucks you up your whole day up your whole day.
Once he smoked weed,
you're pretty much the same for the rest of the Times.
I'm the king of it.
I ain't gonna lie to you
by 11:00.
You're like,
I fucked up.
When you call the doctor's office,
he like,
I ain't going to happen.
Do you tell how many days you take off on a regular firm will take off
for what?
I went to prison.
That was long enough.
Fucking months without smoking.
Weed out of my ass in the fucking sneaking around.
So you're addicted to it.
I'm not addicted to it.
I just can't.
I'm a head dog.
I'm the real deal.
I'm going to smoke dope.
That's my bag.
Some people,
alcoholics and people like to drink.
I can't imagine a life without wheat.
I.
I've been smoking since I was 14.
Have you ever thought,
maybe because you can't imagine because you don't remember it?
No,
I can't imagine it.
Not the front door.
Redman.
I'm the real fucking deal.
I remember.
I know you're the real deal,
so
I just like smoking weed.
The people I grew up,
the type of person I grew up with when I went to Colorado was all around a lot
of heads.
They like weed,
they enjoy.
We when I got home yesterday night and that,
that thing was 31 percent.
I told it in 10 people got back to me.
That said go drive up in San Diego.
That's a head that's not a kid that just,
Oh my God,
I got the boats.
Were Pineapple Express?
No,
there's certain weeds that's got a name that you just smoke it to be cool.
Then there's the shits.
This stuff again,
coach called Matt Number One or g mats.
Number one.
Look at like some famous growers.
Matt is the guy that owns Kush smart,
so when he took her,
he bought that brand and wanting to grow for him and this is a hybrid.
It's a hybrid and that he's got the snoop Dogg that's a 28 percent.
That's how this stuff might be.
The perfect week might be the greatest we'd ever.
I smoked it and I realized when I smoked at the I've been going to CC and I've
been buying $50,
fucking eights and I realized that the part was good and some days when I Bite
Grand Lake by 6:00 after grant was gun,
I'm smoking too much pot.
When the bond,
that's when I hit,
we'd had member that how I started this diet was match.
Oh Gee.
When you smoked in the morning,
the sativa would take over your mind so quickly and I have to get out of the
house before my head blew up and I will have to get on a bike and I would just
get on the bike and pedal because they're chasing me and that's how I lost 100
fucking pounds on that bug smoking to match.
So g,
because it's a Tiva,
wouldn't speed you up by cocaine.
It speed you up at a greg control you.
And it went from being a sativa and to methodically like Endeca.
It was the weirdest.
People don't have standard.
Sativa actually makes the ambitious.
People think that it's the people that look like a pot and you look at people
being potheads being like unambitious and Lazy Sativa makes me way more
ambitious.
It makes me aware of the consequences of not working as hard as you can and how
you feel.
It makes me super sensitive to my own actions,
positive or negative.
So it makes me super sensitive to doing things that I should be doing as far as
like getting work done as far as like,
you know,
writing and performing and you know,
and,
and doing podcasts and it,
I don't ever cancel podcast man,
you know,
after I'd have to be sick as fuck and I don't get sick very often.
So we do.
Um,
you know,
it's like Sativa makes me hyper aware when I'm hyper aware I'm,
I'm more diligent,
you know.
So I think it makes me more ambitious.
But do you guys think if you had,
if you wanted to take a month off,
do you think you could possibly easily do it?
Sure,
I've done that and I haven't taken a month off,
but I've taken weeks off.
I can take a couple of days off.
But why?
Just to see what does this fear factor.
Here's the perfect.
I've tried.
I've thought about it.
You smoke a shitload of weed.
You have to be spending a shit
load of.
I smoke a shitload of weed in the people around me smoke a shitload dog.
It's really weird that the people around me are into it,
like I'm into it,
like the type people we all have fun together and when people don't understand
about marijuana is that they think it's some sort of an escape.
It's an enhancement.
It's not an escape.
We're living in the same world you're living in,
ma'am.
It's just more fun when you're high.
It's really that simple and it's not ruining your body.
It's bullshit.
Pepper on your steak for tate.
Tate.
Can't smoke weed.
You know,
standing up doesn't like weed.
There's a lot of our friends don't like weed.
That's all well and good man.
It's fine.
Yeah.
I mean I've been smoking weed so much that I could take a couple of days off.
I could take probably a week.
I've probably taken a week off recently,
but.
But the,
the idea of taking a month off,
it's so foreign to me.
I almost want to do it just to see what happens.
Like I must blog about it.
She'd become a Republican.
He started watching bill o'reilly.
I have no idea.
It was right.
We do have to be afraid of Mexican.
I haven't stopped smoking weed since 14,
15 to a point in my life,
my career,
I can't write anymore.
When I get really high.
Really?
You're like,
well,
I get up in the morning,
I get high.
It's to go on twitter and facebook and make adjustments here and get my day
ready.
But like now when I write I try to be a little straighter.
Really what I work out.
I got a blaze dog.
If I get good at it.
I had a book I got to get an edible.
I love working out stumped.
That is my life.
That was how I did 30 years ago.
I love not remembering what set it is and I know my shoulders on fire.
You know what I'm saying?
I love the fact that if I get.
If I don't get high,
I still work out an hour and I still do a good job,
but if I work,
if I get high,
I'll work out an our 40 and it's just a little tighter.
I concentrate on my kicks.
I concentrate on the form.
Yeah,
I know what you mean.
Do everything.
When I kicked the bag of them high,
usually I don't usually I kicked the whole holding the bag by mistake.
I will.
I left Brown House with the fucking ankle,
but I like getting on the bike stones because think about it.
I liked the elliptical stone is a fucking different world.
You know how many people were all stoned Jujitsu or you have to.
Everybody does.
No,
no,
no.
I'll tell you,
these classes and these classes,
like you walk in that room,
you smell refer you.
Some everyone smells like refer.
This is like half of his fucking students are high as fuck.
When they take you
a piece of banana cake and you go to yoga.
Oh my God.
But you that that's Mckenna
used to say that that's what yoga was invented for.
Yoga was an advance before was maximizing cannabis.
It was you.
People would be eating cannabis and when they were eating it they realized how
good it felt when you hold your body in certain positions.
So they came up with this like connection to spirituality through eating
cannabis and holding these poses.
These difficult political.
Yeah,
because something.
I don't know what it is about the energy of the pose that makes you go into some
some state when you're high as fuck,
but it really does.
Even if when you're sober,
man,
I've done yoga sober and after it's over,
I felt high.
Well the breathing,
the breathing,
intense breathing that's going through your body and focusing so much on the
breathing.
When I go in and ate a little piece of banana bread because it's 8:30 in the
morning when I got to go to your.
So I gotta start blazing 7:30 by the time.
How long does it take for banana bread or hit you?
Twenty minutes.
Twenty minutes to five minutes and I kick it a little Jaffa,
Jay,
to get everything going.
I didn't have to do other than downward dog.
I've been fucking pigeons.
I've been fun and it's.
And it's you thinking about your breathing is so beautiful.
When you're high,
I want you to go into the water and you have like.
And you could hear your breath like right now.
Yes.
Yeah.
When you do yoga,
you can hear if you hear that you've reached it,
reached that level in that position with the weed.
It makes it a lot easier for me.
I'm a loser.
I know you ain't really.
Like I said,
that's the reason why in Yoga may have very well been invented.
According to Mckenna,
they believe he believes they were,
they invented yoga to maximize the,
the,
the uh,
effects of eating cannabis.
It's something I've gotten high play basketball.
I've got high lifting weights.
There's nothing like eating a little bit of weed and go to yoga.
Even if it's a basic class just to focus on your breathing.
I do it every Tuesday,
like tomorrow I got rush and then go to the airport,
but I'll do it now.
Either that a bowl in the morning because I have nothing else and it is just
fucking breathe my body.
Randy Parsons,
your good friend Ryan Ryan was at the gym.
Would they adjustments and there was an argument going on between trainers and
these guys were white guys.
They weren't heads and the guy was saying that he's been telling all his clients
to,
if police after their workouts,
their weight workouts to smoke a little reefer because it's a anti inflammatory
and it works better than anything else.
Even like the letters should have the ass daddy and muscles.
Lettuce like lettuce.
When you eat lettuce and pulls the acid out of your muscles,
work out something like that.
Acid.
This something.
Let us do something after you work out the acid out of your muscles so they can
recover or something.
Okay.
Well this guy was talking about does that.
We'd done anti inflammatories yes,
and that they're scared to tell people because we'll go fucking crazy.
Well,
it kind of makes sense.
It's a painkiller.
If people enjoy it for a pain,
it kind of makes sense that it would also be,
you know,
for inflammation.
He said it's really good for your joints to do something with the.
Well,
that's one of the reasons they prescribed for arthritis people.
A lot of people that have chronic arthritis,
like I've talked to people that said that they literally couldn't move and then
they would smoke weed and then all of a sudden they could walk around like they
could function,
you know,
it allowed them to be,
to be mobile.
I don't know,
man.
It makes sense.
I mean,
it helps a lot of people in a lot of different ways.
It's just a shame that we have to pretend that something wrong with it.
If people want to think it's not a big deal.
Like why don't you guys talk about we don't fucking losers.
Like first of all,
we're not losers and don't be mean.
And second of all,
it is a fucking important issue,
man.
It is important.
We know ourselves,
how it affects us.
We know ourselves.
How much,
how much more aware.
Thank God you turn his mic off and stick it here and you still go there.
But what I wanted them we 20 years ago is not what I want from me today.
He wanted to escape 20 years ago.
Um,
I liked it.
I have an only child,
so I love living in my head.
Guys,
you give me a fuck.
You let me get my head.
You're a dead man.
Say Yeah,
you let me get my head.
The lonely child.
I'm breaking it down in little time.
I know.
I know what it is to be in the closet.
Playing Gi Joes,
making up your own world and Disneyland is outside your fucking closet.
I'm an only child.
I know how to get the party started my fucking head.
That's why I like being alone.
Even though there's that you can be with and the life pod you go fuck yourself.
Nevermind.
Two o'clock they go fuck yourself.
I'm one of those guys.
Joey will vanish.
Sometimes I could go on an island solo.
I like.
I enjoy.
I don't.
I don't creep out of my skin.
Well listen man,
that's a beautiful quality in comparison to the alternative.
The alternative is someone who needs people around them all the time and needs
attention all the time and everybody knows how God down with knowing that is
rare that someone says extroverted as you,
but also I guess it's just a balance to Yin and Yang,
right?
You need that downtime to.
I really enjoyed my.
I never enjoyed this drop.
My wife.
I always thought you had to be moving with.
That's what kills people.
People don't make enough time for themselves themselves.
And what's that?
A trip to Jamaica.
One hour.
Well,
people don't.
Don't make enough.
Well,
it's hard.
You got to manage your life correctly to to get to a position where you can
enjoy things because some people,
they're just scratching every week.
Man.
Every week is scratching trying to get ahead.
Can't get no fucking traction.
Trying to figure it all out.
That's a tremendous amount of stress,
you know?
Less than an hour.
He came over and were smoking the metallurgy and it was 10 to six or something
and we heard this belt being being Mexican ice cream man,
and it is the best ice cream you'll ever have.
It's dairy queen with ice cream and it makes a delicious banana split.
I'd been there for a year now,
one brown spot over of data,
and it's funny that you said to me,
you get so much enjoyment for the ice cream truck.
Your life is what you make enjoyment.
I'm not filthy loaded,
but I get off on that fucking ice cream man coming
to New York.
I talked to Ralph.
He's in this hotel in the city and I got this and that.
Fuck it.
I'll come around if he doesn't use the Internet because he feels that his
clientele,
he doesn't use the Internet.
I don't know the answer.
That's the most ridiculous thing ever.
He's found the one percent of the population that isn't online.
I mean,
who the fuck isn't online?
That's so silly.
It's just really weird online.
Now,
that expression is so true.
That expression is so true.
When chicken is another man's Gumbo,
did a show with the city and all my friends go to chinatown with do this blog
kind of sucked.
That sucked my place in Richfield park chance dragging,
instilled the pound for pound.
We're in old school.
Chinese food.
You gotta eat more?
I grow shrimp and lobster sauce has been working it.
Old Schools to doodle.
Old School.
Old School 30.
I've been going to answer since 1979 to get steak on a stick.
When I was a sophomore.
They send a cup.
They have one of the best pupil platters and the Chinese food.
So good on the east coast.
Is China closer image right?
The east coast.
New York must be.
You can get great Chinese food out here,
but it's not consistent.
Not everything is good.
I go to a place that the pork fried rice.
You think you're in the bronx but don't get the shipment in Galway.
So it's a lobster cantonese or you feel like you're reading it with a white dude
named Chad lobster.
Cantonese is.
Nobody goes last week.
I'm a city.
Respect lobster,
Cantonese everywhere.
Some people got to eat postured rails.
You and I both know.
You take a little train to fuck in the bronx and you find the mom and pop store
and for 1495 you're going to get hard that you offered the guy 100 bucks.
You could sleep in the back for an hour.
Notice.
When I lived in new Rochelle,
we used to go to frank and knows this.
So frank and John's in new Rochelle is a.
When I lived in new Rochelle is just old school,
Italian place.
The fucking food was so good.
It was right down the street from me.
I never eat anywhere else.
I barely could afford to eat there every day,
but I scraped by everyday,
barely affording it.
Are you drinking more?
You're just going to finish this,
but said,
well,
what do you need to do?
A black casts to let everybody know?
Portland,
Oregon,
baby.
It's all the shows are almost sold out.
And uh,
were there Thursday,
Friday and Saturday at helium comedy club.
And it's going to be fun as fuck.
I can't wait.
I've never done like a long weekend in Portland.
I've only done like one night.
There were there for a UFC.
I did one night in Portland.
Sorry.
Good fucking time.
There's great food.
There's great strip clubs.
We've got little radio.
So we're going out.
Yeah,
we got no radio and your helium is their shit.
Salute.
We didn't and we got to run this house nonstop.
Nonstop jobs with that little comedy tonight.
Brian Cowen is going to be down there at Sal's.
Doug Benson,
Doug Benson is going to be down there and sales sales.
Cami Hall in Hollywood,
which is really.
You're going to see it and you going to go really?
We in the right fucking place.
It says Vianna cafe outside.
It doesn't even have a sign that says sounds comedy on the most low rent ghetto
setup ever.
But it's growing.
And uh,
eventually he's,
well,
he's doing construction is going to have the back.
It's
going to be much better and bigger.
And so this is just a spot.
He had a nice spot and labrea and he's a cool guy and he was always cool to
comics and so we did you.
You recorded a secret.
Would you ever do with that cd?
They recorded that I could use it.
No garbage.
No.
What happened was wrong.
It was really weird job because uh,
if you notice after that I changed everything.
I hate listening to myself or watching myself.
Let's get this out of the way.
I got boxes and shit at the house.
People give me,
hey,
but I taped it.
I don't want to see myself not at all.
And I thought there was a problem and then one that I watched the Johnny Depp on
Letterman and let them set them.
So after the thing he was living in it.
After I shoot,
it's over.
I don't watch myself because really who I felt.
Okay.
I'm not the only retaught.
I don't like nothing about that.
That's why I've never looked into myself doing stand up.
I can't take my voice.
But after I taped that special and listened to it,
I was so ashamed of myself that I made notes in this shit and really helped me.
And I still,
I,
I bring the Ipod,
I taped myself on short sets during the week.
I'm up to like six minutes.
Then I got to shut it off,
you know,
I can't listen to the whole thing and so it's hard to listen to yourself,
but it's good.
It's good because like what you said,
how you,
you force yourself just take five years twisted.
You got to do that,
man.
You got to do that.
You can't just take it on the audience's reaction.
You got to judge it as if you're a comic listening to another comic to,
you know,
when I,
when I listened to my stuff,
I'm wondering how would I feel about this?
Is this funny to me?
You know,
I,
I listened to it and I will forget about how the audience is laughing.
Why does this make me think?
Well,
does this make me.
Do I think this is the right way to do this bit?
Should I shorten this part?
Is this too verbose?
Is this to this or this or that?
And when you do that,
man,
everything gets tighter and stronger.
You focus on it.
It's uncomfortable though.
It's a terrible feeling.
You feel like you're.
It's a weird thing,
man,
or the [inaudible] the same as the energy that brings you to be creative.
The energy that brings you to smash it on stage.
That is not a selfish energy.
People think it is because it seems like it is because you're on stage going
what the fuck?
Cock sucker.
And everyone's laughing and crying,
but to do it right,
to be tuned into those people,
really you have to be almost selfless.
You have to be.
You have to be tuned into this crazy way where it's all just about this fund
that we're having.
It's not about me.
It ain't about me.
You know what I'm saying?
So it's like the opposite that you would get from like someone who like,
listens to themselves.
Like,
yeah,
I'm the shit.
Listen to me,
It's almost like,
just know that that's the police in that thinking like that is the poisoned that
takes away the magic.
Because if you start thinking you're the shadow,
you start thinking,
you know that you're something special and you'll lose your whole connection
with the magic.
You know?
So that's one of the reasons why you feel uncomfortable.
You don't want to listen and you don't want to be that guy who wants to get,
get in my car.
Let's get my new toy set last night telling me what I did.
You ever been to someone's car and they make this mother fucking routine.
Oh,
tell me about this new bit.
Is there anything you could add to this?
Like,
oh Geez.
I wrote the joke.
I want to try it.
Say That on stage and give you a way out,
but don't try.
I've never tried.
I don't try to fucking Bro.
Yeah,
you say it or you don't say it.
Just the idea that you're trying it out.
Look,
it ain't a fucking weapon,
right?
God Damn job a stage.
Do It on a stage.
Take your goddamn chances.
And the more you do that,
the more you know what the fuck's gonna work in the first place.
You don't have to talk to people about stuff like that.
No,
it's crazy because with me,
I have a hard time writing the zone with people.
Like how do I get pissed off?
To a degree before I go on stage,
like I like a little pistol office.
When you get mad you get like fake arguments with people.
I want to do that one time.
Eddie Bravo.
We were all in the back at the House of Blues and he's like,
you guys with your fucking bullshit.
You're a fucking man.
And he's like,
why is she getting upset?
I'm like,
he's just got to put himself in that place.
He's not really.
No,
I'm not mad at nobody,
but he's getting these fucking guys fucking.
Oh,
I need to use a vaporizer.
Listen,
I was smoking weed with an apple when I was five.
Crazy how?
Whatever around you guys sometimes just be mad.
Makes me say somebody like,
Joey,
you got to fucking say that
and I'll forget for a month.
I'll forget.
And you guys like Joe was fucking stage yet.
I'm like,
you like when you guys got a forced me like your records keeper.
I'm always telling them shit.
Did you do.
Do you still doing that thing about a dead Dick?
You still doing that thing?
Yeah,
but the soldier don't say anymore,
please.
People must see that on stage.
Uh,
when you did that,
we have that video still.
Do you have that video?
You got to do something with that video.
But just even if it's for internal use only,
I need to see that set.
GimMe that set please Brian,
send it to you already know you did that joey from.
From Bria.
It was last night,
right?
It was Sunday night.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I've never seen anybody killed hardening that.
The only thing that was closer to someone killing harder than that was when you
killed in Vegas at the Mandalay Bay theater.
Holy Shit.
When you were doing that bit about fucking having that fistfight with the nun.
I might not have ever laughed that hard at anything ever in my whole life.
It was the funniest thing I've ever seen
Mr. comedy store.
And that's the bad thing because during the week that's what you would enjoy
laughing at each other like each other.
And that really took away from my career because you see bill burga Tuesday and
water die.
You know,
he don't care.
He's so confident was extended up.
Are you willing to try different things and you know,
we always get into conversations and style joke about the store that at the end
they will come to whatever,
but you know,
I don't take away the truth from anything.
That's what's really lacking.
I wish we had south is becoming thousands becoming.
I know we just need some more people to go on their support.
I've been out of town on Wednesdays.
We've got a plenty of plenty of people.
Bill burroughs was by last week.
Sarah Silverman was by the week before and it's Doug Benson is coming down all
the time.
Steve Reynolds easy came and crushed it.
Katt Williams to meet that dude that's still never met.
That dude.
He is.
Is he in jail?
I'm a big fan of that dude.
That dude makes me laugh.
He makes me laugh like very few dudes.
He's one of my top favorite guys to watch how it's like if someone sends me a
clip,
someone sends me a clip and says like,
Hey,
check out this cat Williams clip that fucking thing where he was going after
Steve Harvey.
Oh Shit.
That's funny.
And one of the things that accentuate something and as they accentuates it,
he slides across the room,
like he's kicking someone in the nuts and as he does it,
he goes,
I'm a little Nigga,
I fight dirty.
And he slides slides of the stage.
Lewis a little flip up in the attic.
He's kicking somebody in the balls.
I remember one man,
he makes me laugh hard.
We're talking about it.
But you have no idea that numbers.
He does.
How he does crazy.
He goes,
you got to a place where we go to the UFC,
the,
he does that.
He does the Pearl at the palms.
That's like 5,000 seats.
That's a big ass place.
They have big bands there.
Katt Williams cells that fucker out man.
And there's pictures of him in the casino with like fur coats on and shit.
And diamonds.
He's hilarious man.
He,
that dude really makes me laugh because he's just going for it all the time.
He's not trying to be anything other than he is.
He's just trying to be funny.
He's just going for it all the time.
Gone for the funny going for the funny and he's fucking good dude.
He does a funny thing about fucking Shaquille o'neal trying to be a cop.
Doing fucking hilarious is how Shaquille O'Neal's three year old was his height.
Yeah.
Oh really?
That's special.
And that thing that he did on Michael Jackson that made him a star.
When you watched that bit on Youtube,
you watch that and you see the black people.
They don't even know how to act because you see the truth.
See,
the truth is a motherfucker when you say it the right way and that stays even if
it's wrong.
What he was saying.
Where's Michael Jackson?
He's probably smelled a little babies.
Booty hole.
Is this something that is a classic fucking La and he just runs from there with
it guys?
Yeah,
he.
He runs with it and said,
when was the last time you seen Michael Jackson with a woman?
Not because all that crazy shit,
bro.
That shit was that made them ms dot that little piece of him been themselves.
Just that little piece,
that complex.
Pray for that.
You opiod a couple of days.
It's important to have guys like that out there.
I like guys that are just going for it.
You know?
I liked guys are out there just fucking going for it.
There's a lot of people that think that comedy is comedy is about the respect of
your peers and creating the proper clever joke with the right wording and it's
not man.
It's about entertainment value.
If it's about your standup comedy and to these these days,
man,
you comedy doesn't even nearly have to be that deep anymore.
If you want to get deep man,
why you tell you know you,
you can.
You could do a podcast and get deep.
You could write a blog and get deep.
You know you could.
You could have a conversation with an intelligent person.
Get to.
You don't have to get that deep of your comedy.
It's shit that makes me laugh.
Is Kat Williams the floor kicking some dude in the book.
I'm a little Nigga.
I fight dirty
and what he does and it's so natural.
It's so funny,
man.
Oh,
that God kills me,
man.
He's got some great shit.
I,
you know what he had,
he actually had some real good advice too that I took.
He said that uh,
he listens to a,
he has on his ipod,
he has like a playlist of all music that he listens to right before he goes on
stage.
And I'm like damn,
that's a great idea because I have just like a group of like some of my favorite
songs on my ipod that I just,
I throw on,
it's on my iphone too.
I'll throw them on like when I'm at the gym or whatever,
whatever.
But I don't have a specific list just for,
for standup,
but that's a good fucking idea.
It's a real good idea.
So I started doing that.
I started doing that just based on that,
because I know music,
if you listen to like the right kind of music,
you know the right kind of music and fucking get you in a good groove man,
you know,
especially if you haven't.
Sometimes when you listen to music too much,
if you lose it's power,
you don't have that feeling anymore and just loses its impact.
But every now and then a song which is Jack you and let you know what's
possible.
Member,
when we were at the Brian Improv and we were in the parking lot and I had that
Nissan truck and you got out and that,
that crazy sound system in and you got out of your car,
you're like Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan put this fucking CD and right now Donna summer hot stuff.
You put on hot stuff
sitting here in my greatest success.
Some music drives you fucking nuts.
I love music.
I love loving skin that listen to loads.
It mainly the old shit.
Oh,
I love landscaping.
I love almond brothers from the seventies.
Lennon skinner.
I love that vibe,
man.
There's something about that time,
like if I'm in a pool hall and sweet home,
Alabama comes on.
It's like,
like your girlfriend just comes over and rubs your neck.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like someone comes over and gives you a hug like that.
So I don't know.
You hear that?
Oh sweet.
So what a great song.
Guns,
blue singing it.
They're singing it,
man.
We'd hold.
Why do you think you were good at your finger?
On the trigger?
What are you doing?
Just waiting for a to get out of here.
How long have you been doing this?
At?
Seven,
15.
Just we're going to be late for a show,
whatever.
So we're a couple minutes late.
This is a whole internet out that I'm running the show,
which is even better because they can't go there without you being there.
I can't start it too.
I got to go.
He did it.
Two guys.
This is it.
This is how we're going to end this fucking thing.
Fifteen,
seven,
20.
That's it too.
Wow.
This is the end.
My only friend.
The thank you to the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net,
entering the code neighbor Rogan,
you will get 15 percent off the flashlights.
We will see you this weekend in Portland,
Oregon at helium comedy club,
Thursday,
Friday and Saturday.
It's mad flavor.
Aka Joe Diaz,
Aka Planet Rock and show up with no wag.
We'd only the best motherfuckers.
Brian redband walls will be performing on stage two and then a rocket this week.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for tuning in and we will see guys,
they black motherfuckers.
We love you.
Either Monday or Tuesday.
We're trying to get a Kevin from attack of the show.
He should be on holiday.
Oh,
Bert crisis is going to be on to what.